الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كانت قتلت شابين
فلسطينيين خلال توغلها في مخيم بلاطه شرق
مدينه نابلس صباح اليوم وافاد الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني بان سبعه اخرين اصيبوا
بجروح مختلفه بعدما اطلقت قوات الاحتلال
الرصاصه على المواطنين الذين ترجمهاروا
عند مداخل المخيم واضاف ان قوات الاحتلال
سدت منافذ المخيم ومنع الطواقم الاسعاف من
نقل المصابين وكانت قواتنا اسرائيليه خاصه
توغلت وسط المخيم وحاصرت منزلا في حاره
الجماسين المكتظه بالسكان ثم طلبت من
الموجودين في المنزل تسليم انفسهم مهدده
بالقصف كما فتحت نيران اسلحتها على كل من
حاول الاقتراع
من جهتها افاده اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
بان القوات الاسرائيليه فشلت في اعتقال
المطلوب في عمليه نابلس في احد المنازل من
مخيم بلاطه شرقيه نابلس تنضم الينا جفار
البديري جيفارا اقتحام هذا المخيم ليس
وحده يعني اقتحامات مستمره
للقوات الاسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه
بالطبع عثمان قواتها الاحتلال ليلى نهار
تقتحم هنا وهناك في اي موقع وقريه ومخيم
داخل انحاء مختلفه من الضفه الغربيه لنحدث
اخر التطورات هنا في المخيم قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي انسحبت قبل حوالي الساعه من
داخل المخيم ومن محيط مخيم بلاطه شرق
مدينه نابلس الان تم نقل جثماني الشهيدين
سائد مشه وعدنان الاعرج الذين استشهداء
برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الان هما يعني
الجثمانين في الثلاجه في داخل مستشفى
رفيديا في مدينه نابلس والتحضيرات لتشجيع
الجثمانيين متواصله لا يعرف ان كانت ستكون
الجنازه اليوم او يوم غد ايضا هناك سيده
مسنه تجاوزت الخمسين من عمرها اصيبت
باربع رص في منطقه البطن والحوض الاهالي
هنا يتساءلون ما دخل هذه السيده
بالعمليه العسكريه هي ليست مسلحه كانت
امنه في منزلها ايضا الصور التي تم نشرها
للشهدين الذين استشهد صباح اليوم كانت
مروعه جدا حيث ان الرصاص قام بتهشيم
الراسين وبالتالي حاله كبيره جدا من الغضب
تسود هنا مخيم بلاطه الذي كانت وحده من
الكوماندوز الاسرائيلي وككل مره وايضا
وحده من المستعربين قد تسللت الى ما تعرف
بحاله الجماسين وهي في اطراف داخليه جدا
ومعقده داخل مخيم بلاطه هي مكتظه بالسكان
فور اكتشاف المقاومين الفلسطينيين لهذه
الوحده قامت قوات الاحتلال بادخال تعزيزات
كبيره جدا الى المخيم والى محيط جنود
الاحتلال اسطح المنازل قاموا باطلاق النار
بشكل عشوائي على كل من يتحرك ويمر ايضا
وفق مصادر طبيه فلسطينيه الطواقم الطبيه
تعرضت لاطلاق النار خاصه بقنابل الصوت
لمنعها من الدخول كان يمكن انقاذ الشهيدان
ككل الشهداء في كل مره كان يمكن انقاذهم
لكن قوات الاحتلال تمنع الطواقم الطبيه من
الدخول كما ايضا نضيف بان قوات
الطواقم الطبيه ومصادر محليه فلسطينيه
اكدت ان قوات الاحتلال لم تطلق صاروخ
انرجا على المنزل بل طوقته يبدو انها قامت
بعمليه تفجير خارجيه ومن ثم وفق مصادر
اسرائيليه تم تفجير عبوات في داخل المنزل
كان على كانت على ما يبدو مجهزه لتنفيذ
هجمات ضد اهداف اسرائيليه ولكن ذلك لم
يؤكد من اي مصدر
الجيش الاسناد ايضا اكدت بان قوه
الاحتلال ما هدف هذه هي الاقتحامات هل هو
القبض على مطلوبين الجانب الاسرائيلي هل
هو البحث عن اماكن ربما تنطلق منها عمليات
معينه ضد الاسرائيليين الاقتحامات
المتكرره هذه ليل نهار كما قلت في الضفه
الغربيه ما الهدف منها
بالطبع المزاعم الاسرائيليه طوال الوقت هي
الوصول الى من تقول انهم مطلوبون لدى
الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه اما
بالاعتقال او بالاختيال ولكن اليوم مثلا
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي تقول ان الجيش فشل
في عمليه بمعنى الوصول الى مطلوبه كانت
تريد اعتقاله ويبدو انه ايضا كانت تريد
تنفيذ عمليه اغتيال يعني لنوضح اكثر
عثمان منذ بدايه هذا العام نتحدث عن خمسه
اشهر 150 شهيدا فلسطينيا سقطوا بينهم
بالطبع 33 شهيدا من قطاع غزه خلال هذا
العدوان هذا عدد كبير جدا وكانت مؤسسات
حقوقيه دوليه قد اكدت انه هذا العام
كالعام الماضي لا يقارن بالعدد من السنوات
الدمويه خاصه في بدايه سنوات انتفاضه
الاقصى من عام 2001 عام حتى عام 2006 اذا
العدد يرتفع كل يوم تقريبا كل يوم هناك
اعتقالات ويوم بعد يوم هناك اما عمليه
اغتيال او مجزره
الان مكبرات الصوت هنا في مخيم بلاطه
وايضا في مدينه نابلس تعلن عن تشييع
جثماني الشهيدين اذا الان مكبرات الصوت في
المساجد تعلن ان جنازه الشهيدين سائد مشي
والشهيد الاعرج ستنطلق من داخل المستشفى
رفيديا في مدينه نابلس على ما يبدو الى
هنا الى مخيم بلاطه ولكن نحن يعني الصوت
مشوش نوعا ما نحن نحاول ان نفهم اكثر ولكن
حتى نفهم فقط نعيد ونذكر ان العدد كبير
جدا هذا ما دفع اليوم السلطه الفلسطينيه
تحديدا الرئاسه الفلسطينيه الى اصدار بيان
عاجل حملت فيها الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تداعيات الاوضاع الميدانيه في قطاع غزه
وانها تجاوزت كل الخطوط الحمراء وان
استمرار هذا التجاوز معناه تغيير الواقع
بر والذهاب الى انفجار ولكن ما كان لافت
في بيان الرئاسه الفلسطينيه هو تحميل
الاداره الامريكيه بشكل اكبر واوسع وبشكل
مباشر بان الاداره الامريكيه هي من تتحمل
مسؤوليه انفجار الاوضاع الميدانيه خاصه
ايضا في قطاع غزه بسبب عدم تدخلها المباشر
لوقف اسرائيل عن كل هذا العدوان وعن
العمليات المتواصله التي لا تتوقف ليله
نهار ايضا كان الاتحاد الاوروبي قد اصدر
بيانات خلال الايام الماضيه اعرب فيه عن
قلقه البالغ ازاء التطورات التي تحدث بشكل
دراماتيكي في قطاع غزه ويبدو ان الامور
يعني متواصله هي متواصله بالفعل عثمان في
قطاع غزه ولكن هذا منذ ثلاثاء الماضي ولكن
هنا في الضفه الغربيه منذ عام ونصف لم
تتوقف هذه العمليات شكرا لك جيفارا البدي